the latest casualty of the Donald Trump
president of train wreck continue today
with the fast-food executive Andrew
puzzler withdrawing his nomination for
Secretary of Labor leaving him free to
go back to his job being the guide
Illuminati sex parties who shouts ass to
ass that's definitely him
so all the tribe we need to acknowledge
that football stud 6969
yeah I know it was a bummer that there
are already six thousand nine hundred
and sixty eight football studs this
Trump drama never ends yeah every day it
feels like an episode of Game of Thrones
where you're like how can they keep
cramming all this drama and treachery
and you're such a short amount of time
we just need a Lizabeth Warren to swoop
in on a dragon or Justin Trudeau to show
his dick like Hodor
[Applause]
it's why did that it yeah it is it's
gorgeous that's in it's in Canadian I
can get me maple syrup lube you got it
next up what do you think what crisis do
you think the Trump administration will
face tomorrow and I can buzz in well we
ton uh Kellyanne Conway will deny her
own existence
I think that's mr. drew Carey they're
gonna run out of feet to shoot
themselves in all right points Heather
Anne Campbell I trumpet Putin will be
caught in bed 1969 a yes